[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue dans ce
journal
voici les titres de ce lundi 24 février
le salon de l'agriculture a démarré ce
week end à paris cette année encore les
yvelines et les hauts-de-seine partagent
un stand commun sur place le département
deuxième territoire agricole d'île de
france avec près de 1000 exploitations
et 2000 emplois
toute cette semaine la rédaction de tv
60,18 vous propose un dossier sur les
femmes qui ont marqué l'histoire des
yvelines vous la connaissez forcément
romy-schneider avait qu à boissy sans
avoir l'actrice autrichienne y est
aujourd'hui toujours enterré enfin la
page dédiée aux élections municipales
aux clayes-sous-bois elle porte une
candidature citoyenne et sans étiquette
stéphanie jamin et la tête de liste
d'énergie positive qui prône l'écologie
et la solidarité
et puis à suivre aussi dans cette
édition ce qu'il faut retenir des
résultats sportifs dans le département
[Musique]
l'actualité du jour c'est le salon
international de l'agriculture qui a
débuté ce week-end à paris un rendez
vous où les politiques aussi se pressent
chaque année dans les pavillons de la
porte de versailles pour la troisième
année consécutive yvelines et odyssey et
hauts-de-seine font stand commun dans la
perspective et de leur fusion les
présidents des deux départements étaient
présents sur place ce matin à nicolas
kirillovitch leur a posé trois questions
[Musique]
évidemment nous avons quelques vestiges
archéologiques de l'agriculture avec
quelques vignes plus symbolique que
réelle
non les hauts-de-seine c'est pas une
terre agricole il faut le dire
loyalement c'est même le plus petit
département de france qu'on ne sait pas
toujours
on produit du vin à suresnes on produit
aussi un peu de vin à bagneux il ya
quelques vestiges comme ça mais c'est
plutôt de manière folklorique
on n'a pas de prétention agricole les
yvelines dont près de la moitié de leur
territoire en agriculture et si vous
comptez la forêt car la forêt viennoise
est très importante et c'est une
ressource naturelle qui aura de plus en
plus d'importance à la frontière puisque
nous comptons développer la construction
par le bois et l'énergie par le bois est
bien plus des deux tiers du département
des yvelines sont des espaces naturels
look c'est non seulement un art de vivre
une qualité de vie mais c'est aussi une
dimension économique considérable
ça représente des centaines pardon des
milliers d'emplois donc c'est important
mais c'est surtout images non si nous
n'avions pas les agriculteurs
si nous n'avions pas les exploitants
de forêt nous serions obligés nous
puissance publique d'entretenir ces
espaces donc ça nous coûteraient des
sommes folles nous avons la chance
d'avoir à la fois des activités
économiques créatrices de richesses mais
aussi ses activités économiques
créatrices de richesses sont des
activités d'intérêt général puisqu'elle
nous permettent de bénéficier de
paysages admirable se promener dans les
yvelines le week-end après une dure
semaine de travail qu'est ce qu'il y a
de mieux
[Musique]
ce sont des marchés potentiels
considérables puisque il y a autant
d'élèves scolarisés dans les collèges du
département des hauts-de-seine que des
yvelines et nous avons l'ambition de
développer les circuits courts les
circuits courts c'est-à-dire la
production de légumes
la production de viande sur les
territoires où ils sont consommés et
comme dans les hauts-de-seine ils ne
peuvent pas produire plus il n'ya pas
des espaces agricoles
ils sont tout à fait disposés à
consommer les produits des agriculteurs
yvelinois et j'ajouterai que nous avons
aussi sur nos territoires et en
particulier dans les hauts-de-seine des
entreprises qui ont des restaurants
d'entreprise qui vont se convertir aussi
à ses circuits courts donc il y a la
possibilité d'accompagner la mutation
inéluctable de l'agriculture
francilienne qui était très exportatrice
de céréales autrefois qui essaye de le
rester mais qui a de grandes difficultés
face à la concurrence internationale en
particulier de l'ukraine et de
l'argentine est donc prouve
des débouchés à proximité c'est à la
fois pour le consommateur un gage de
qualité et pour l'agriculteur un gage de
revenus un accord gagnant-gagnant en
quelque sorte et ça nous permet d'avoir
des produits frais des produits même sur
commande adaptée à nos besoins notre
demande et donc il ya une profonde
complémentarité nous avons plutôt des
entreprises d'agroalimentaire dans les
hauts-de-seine mais nous n'avons pas de
production agricole naturellement et
nous nous sommes malheureux dans les
hauts-de-seine d'être si urbanisées
d'être si dense et quand on va dans les
yvelines
on a grâce aux relations que nous avons
le sentiment aussi d'être chez nous et
c'est un autre univers
vous savez malheureusement depuis qu'on
ne veut redonner dans des territoires si
dense où on ne plante plus grand chose
on en est à l'agriculture urbaine c'est
à dire que on plante des arbres sur les
toits vous voyez ou à quelle folie on en
arrive c'est paris qui nous a évidemment
contaminé avec cette folie dans les
yvelines nous avons totalement
sacraliser les terres agricoles et en
particulier nous avons donc créé un
organisme qui s'appelle bio dif et cet
organisme biodyvin consiste à compenser
chaque fois qu'il ya un projet
urbanistique en créant de nouveaux
espaces agricoles donc non seulement ne
voulons pas les consoler mais nous
voulons en ré ouvrir et c'est un travail
qui est complètement contemporain
cette idée selon laquelle la terre
agricole et quelque chose d'un fini
c'est une idée du passé
aujourd'hui nous le savons que la rareté
de nos ressources doit être infiniment
préserver et on s'inscrit totalement
dans cette dynamique et l'émission 7,8
société sera cette semaine consacrée à
ce salon de l'agriculture
améliorer la réussite dans les quartiers
prioritaires la réussite scolaire dans
les quartiers prioritaires l'objectif
des sites et éducatives un dispositif
dont fait partie trap est lancé par le
gouvernement les ministres de
l'éducation nationale et de la ville ont
annoncé une enveloppe de 100 millions
d'euros pour les 80 territoires
labellisés comme tel
ce budget doit permettre de financer des
actions concrètes sur le temps scolaire
mais aussi périscolaires et
extrascolaires qui implique donc les
acteurs éducatifs associatifs culturels
sportifs et économiques
le but est d'accompagner chaque jeune
depuis la petite enfance jusqu'à
l'insertion professionnelle ou vont à
présent notre dossier de la rédaction
qui va nous accompagner toute cette
semaine tv 78 vous fait découvrir le
parcours de femmes qui ont marqué
l'histoire des yvelines coup de
projecteur ce soir sur romy schneider
qui a vécu dans le département alliés
est aujourd'hui toujours enterré c'est
ici que son destin va basculer avec la
mort de son fils à saint germain en laye
ce le récit de michael et demi d'euros
c'est moi
connell veuillez dire aux comptes entre
ainsi que je les choisis comme cavalier
à vos ordres majesté son visage a marqué
l'histoire du cinéma pendant plus de
trois décennies l'autrichienne romy
schneider né en 1938 à vienne a tourné
dans des dizaines de films
l'important c'est d'aimer la piscine ou
encore la trilogie si si autant de
classiques lui ont valu une
reconnaissance internationale et des
récompenses dont deux césar dansant
mirabel spécialiste cinéma se souvient
d'abord elle était formidablement
photogénique
il n'y a pas un film romy schneider ne
soit pas belle et puis le deuxième atout
qu'elle avait c'était un extraordinaire
professionnalisme elle était capable
avec son visage d'éprouver énormément de
sentiments et d'être à la fois une femme
ordinaire ou bien extraordinaire dans
une situation extraordinaire elle était
émouvante et même bouleversant en dehors
des plateaux romy schneider fasciné
également le public son couplet qu alain
delon de 1958 à 1963 fut l'un des plus
médiatiques et mythiques de l'histoire
du cinéma
alain delon et romy schneider étaient
surnommés les fiancés de l'europe
ils étaient beaux comme des dieux tous
les deux follement amoureux et pourtant
romy schneider a eu ce chagrin de ne
jamais être épousé par alain delon
après avoir vécu à hollywood ou encore à
paris c'est en 1980 que la route de romy
schneider croise celle du département
des yvelines
l'actrice y achète une maison de
campagne à la fin de sa vie
romy schneider a besoin de s'isoler un
peu par rapport à la vie mondaine
parisienne et elle va trouver un havre
de paix à boissy sans avoir dans la
plaine de montfort l'amaury mais c'est
dans la commune de saint germain les que
le destin de romy schneider va basculer
en plein coeur de l'été on est en 1981
et david
le fils de romy schneider et d'arrimer
yens le premier mari de romy schneider
tentent de rejoindre la propriété de
grands pas et il va s'empaler sur la
grille qu'il tentait d'escalader
l'artère fémorale est touché
il mourra dans les heures qui suivent
david décède à l'hôpital de
saint-germain-en-laye à l'âge de 14 ans
romy schneider ne s'en remettra pas
quelques mois plus tard le 29 mai 1982
son corps est retrouvé inanimé la cause
et non défini la star avait 43 ans
l'actrice est inhumé au cimetière de
boissy sans avoir un lieu où l'actrice
repose aujourd'hui avec son fils david
il tombe toujours fleurie par ses fans
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut retenir des résultats
sportifs du week-end dans le département
avec michael est lié doro bonsoir ans
argue journalistes aux sports de la
rédaction de tv 78 on démarre une fois
n'est pas coutume par un résumé le match
avec du football auquel une partie à des
quarts de finale de coupe des yvelines
de football était programmé ce week-end
montigny-le-bretonneux recevait maurepas
match où il n'y a finalement pas eu
match les morts bazian se sent
facilement imposé 4 à 0 en contrôlant la
rencontre le résumé montigny le
bretonneux maurepas c'était l'une des
affiches de ces quarts de finale de
coupe des yvelines dès l'entamé du match
maurepas qui évolue en d1 de district
assume son statut de favori sept
divisions d'écart et leurs patients se
procurent les meilleures occasions et
arrive à marquer deux fois 2 à 0 ce sera
le score à la pause ça se passe pas très
bien on a respecté les consignes du
coach
après ils ont marqué sur une attaque
rapide et
on se fait contrer ils ont une deuxième
au casque qui met au fond voilà pour
essayer de faire le nécessaire pour
revenir au déjà 2 1 après poussé pour
ces d'égaliser sur une tête juste garder
la possession ses traits ce qu'on a fait
en première mi-temps garde à vue un
système tranquillement le troisième va
venir sûrement tout seul ça va s'ouvrir
un peu plus espace matisse se livrèrent
pour sortir pour l'environnement avec le
premier pour nous titille un peu mais
vraiment sans le savoir le défenseur
tristan feely a vu juste quelques
minutes après la reprise ils coupent
belfodil réalise un petit numéro dans la
surface avant de marquer à 3 0 savage
arriva j'arrive à bien effacer finale
avec un petit piqué franchement c'est
j'ai bien aimé ce lama après je garde
tous ses débuts de bopa bout un but un
but pas encore rassasié yacoub belfodil
s'offre même un triplé en fin de match
maurepas l'emportent 4 à 0 c'est
frustrant on se fait éliminer
salma bref pas grand chose à dire nous
apparaît match de coupe on aurait dit
elle était un peu plus de la rame et en
entraide en a l'envié
on a maîtrisé on savait que on savait
qu'on avait les qualités des vhu défense
effet offenser pour pouvoir faire la
différence si j'ai une division en
dessous ont conservé et qu'on partait
avec un petit avantage
après voilà maintenant on a su on a su
montrer les cartes cave entre nous le
prochain tour de la coupe des yvelines
est programmée le dimanche 5 à brommat
on a bien apprécié amical lé but de
jakub belfodil bravo à lui et bravo à
l'équipe de maurepas on continue avec du
football américain
cette fois ci les templiers d'elancourt
en mode rouleau compresseur les élans
courtois n'ont pas fait de détail ce
samedi 22 février à domicile contre
leeds au coeur de nantes les élégants
courtois l'emportent sur le score de 51
à 0 après avoir dominé l'ensemble de la
partie et réactions c'est une belle
victoire
on a on a été plein partout autant en
défense qu'en attaque
franchement ça fait ça fait vraiment
plaisir de voir que mes coéquipiers
prennent du plaisir et
du coup voilà on a on a montré ce qu'on
avait à montrer maintenant certes on a
fait beaucoup de fautes et on va
apprendre de nos erreurs et référent
essayé tournus au classement les
templiers d'elancourt se replace cette
troisième victoire en quatre matches
leur permet d'occuper la deuxième place
de leur poule derrière les léopards de
rouen les pf de fin de saison sont donc
accessibles ainsi qu'une montée en
première division c'est un objectif
maintenant on en est encore loin là
c'est plutôt en phase de playoffs on
pourra avoir une vraie indication sur
sûr sur cette question mais ça reste un
de nos objectifs
maintenant c'est une marche qui est très
très hot on a encore beaucoup de
beaucoup de travail et pas mal de
matches mais on va on va pousser en fait
au plus loin pour pour atteindre cet
objectif
prochain match pour les templiers
d'elancourt le 1er mars prochain sur le
terrain des diables rouges de villepinte
en attendant les éléments courtois
peuvent savourer grégory allez un
dernier résultat avec du rugby dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir cette
inclinés 38 à 13 sur le terrain de
beauvais ce week-end l'une des
meilleures équipes de la poule
au classement les plaisirs oies sont
toujours à la limite de la zone de
relégation avec un point d'avancé sur
orléans
merci michael lassus de l'actualité
sportive yvelinoise à retrouver dans
votre émission le 7-8 sport c'est après
ce journal et puisqu'on parle de sport
les clubs du département avaient rendez
vous hier dimanche dans un restaurant de
guyancourt un moment autour d'une pizza
partagé pour se faire connaître et aussi
rapprocher les différentes disciplines
football américain badminton ou encore
judo parmi les associations présentes
en tout une quinzaine de club yvelinois
à participer à ce rendez vous organisé
par sport event 60,18 les propos
recueillis par vous michael et demi
d'euros on va donc présenter un petit
peu tout le monde
succinctement chacun va présenter ses
activités
les différents événements à venir ça
permet de huy de faire du lien de sortir
de chez soi et de montrer que malgré ma
grille qu'on a eu un cancer du sein ou
autres cancers
on peut faire des activités et prouver
que le sport est une activité très
importante dans la maladie ça permet
tout simplement de faire des contacts
dans un premier temps et puis d'exposer
des idées qui pourraient
qui pourrait je pense
à d'autres associations
se faire connaître et puis comme j'ai
entendu
pourquoi pas travailler dans l'avenir
quoi la deuxième partie de ce journal
consacré aux élections municipales j -
20 avant le premier tour du scrutin le
15 mars prochain
et du côté de mantes-la-ville les cinq
candidatures annoncées ont déjà déposé
leurs listes la date du limite de limite
du dépôt des candidatures est fixée au
27 février
à commencer par cyril notre mère depuis
2014 maire sortant depuis le 2014 seuls
élus du rassemblement national en
ile-de-france il repart avec cinq et de
ses adjoints et une équipe en partie
renouvelée
elle porte le printemps de
mantes-la-ville une liste de gauche
soutenue par le parti socialiste le
parti communiste et europe ecologie les
verts
hamiti smith d'agi mn campagne avec sa
colistière monique brochot ancien maire
ps de la commune une ancienne première
magistrate
annette peulvast bergeal figurent aussi
parmi les membres d'une autre liste
union pour mantes la ville
ça me samia d'énergie en est la tête de
liste il est soutenu par la république
en marche pas d'anciens maires mais un
ancien adjoint en renfort de dernière
minute sur la liste mentent en mouvement
elle est conduite par éric visite nerfs
et soutenu par libre le mouvement de
valérie pécresse est le conseil
municipal d'opposition de centre-droit
était déjà en lice en 2014
enfin nous mentent villois une
candidature à gauche et à vocation
citoyenne et elle porté par romain
carbone la liste est déjà officialisé il
ya presqu'un an et déposé depuis
plusieurs semaines en préfecture et des
nouveaux candidats se déclarent pour ce
scrutin des élections municipales en fin
de semaine dernière lutte ouvrière
présentait ses huit listes engagées dans
les yvelines l'une d'entre elles est aux
clayes-sous-bois l'autre est engagé
attrape les précisions de mélanie poquet
de michael ni d'euros il y aura donc oui
liste du tout vrillière dans les
yvelines pour faire entendre comme ils
disent la voix des travailleurs même au
niveau local pour le scrutin du 15 mars
prochain la formation a choisi de se
représenter aux clayes-sous-bois une
troisième candidature après 2008 et 2014
déjà menées à l'époque par olivier
augustin employé chez renault flins on
défend des idées
lee
que dans cette société là il ya vraiment
deux camps et qu'on pourra pas s'en
sortir sans mener la guerre contre ceux
aujourd'hui qui nous amène nous c'est
surtout cette idée là qu'on veut faire
passer
on a réussi à monter donc encore cette
fois-ci de liste lutte ouvrière donc sur
les clayes-sous-bois qui rassemble 33
candidats et candidates
les cheminots que les agents
hospitaliers les agents de service ou
des ouvriers du bâtiment soit bref qui
est vraiment à l'image de toute la
population ouvrière aux clayes-sous-bois
lutte ouvrière également représenté
attrape la liste sera menée par patrick
planque ouvriers de maintenance à la
sncf
autour de lui des cheminots du personnel
de santé ou encore des agents de
nettoyage
cette ville
est intéressante parce que
effectivement c'est une ville ouvrière
avec une longue histoire de lutte
quand même qui a appartenu longtemps au
pc mais en tout cas avec plus de trois
mille cheminots qui habitait dans cette
ville il ya quelques années encore du
coup sa marque réellement les esprits et
quand on parle aujourd'hui de recréer un
parti à parti d'une travailleurs un
parti ouvrier qui organiserait les
choses dans les quartiers qui
organiserait les choses dans la ville
est bien dans les plus anciens il ya une
petite étoile
six autres candidats ont déposé leur
liste dans les yvelines à poissy
conflans sainte honorine aubergenville
carrières sous poissy mantes la jolie et
aux mureaux cinq candidats en tout aux
clayes-sous-bois il ya également
stéphanie jamin bonsoir on ça vous êtes
la tête de liste d'énergie positive une
démarche citoyenne et sans étiquette
vous êtes clé sienne depuis plus de 30
ans dans la vie vous est elle
responsable responsable administrative
et financière impliqué dans le milieu
associatif local pourquoi vous lancer
cette fois ci dans une démarche
politique
alors du coup on se lance avec une
équipe dans cette démarche de des
municipales pour pour le mois de mars
prochain puisque on a senti depuis
quelque temps que les claies avait
besoin d'un nouveau dynamisme d'un
rajeunissement de l'équipe municipale
donc nous avons souhaité proposer une
liste citoyenne soutenue par aucun parti
politique pour proposer un regard
nouveau
oak les siens donc citoyenne ça veut
dire que ces composés de personnes qui
ne sont pas engagés dans le conseil
municipal des clayes-sous-bois
effectivement donc on est aussi parti du
constat que les trois listes
enfin la quatrième liste n'était pas
encore sorti mais que les trois listes
en présence permettait de reconstituer
la totalité hormis deux personnes il me
semble du conseil municipal actuel donc
donc on a voulu proposer quelque chose
de différent il y avait aussi cette
interrogation sur sur madame frémont et
monsieur guy guen qui vont tous voter
pendant 14 ans ensemble et qui
maintenant se sont se sont ne
s'entendait plus donc en fait on saisit
que les caissières méritait mieux qu'une
guerre une guerre et une liste citoyenne
était importante tant les municipales
précise sans parler de deux listes qui
sont également engagés qui sont
conduites par deux actuel adjoint de la
commune des clayes-sous-bois les clayes
sous bois où la maire sortante véronique
côté millard à ne se représentera pas
elle est élue depuis 2001 à la tête de
la commune quel regard vous portez sur
l'action portée par véronique côté
millard à la tête des clayes sous bois
alors effectivement je trouve que son
bilan il ya des très belles choses qui
ont pu être faites
enfin il faut tout n'est pas négatif aux
clayes-sous-bois sinon je ne serais pas
resté enfin parce que j'y suis revenue
quand j'ai voulu fonder ma famille donc
clairement je ne serais pas resté si
tous ne me plaisait pas mais moi en
terme de bilan on est assez mitigé on a
un peu du mal à comprendre quel est le
bilan de madame véronique côté millard
hormis le manque de transparence sur la
communication sur les différents projets
également sur l'engagement de la
dernière campagne pour revenir sur nos
centres de loisirs des bruyères campagne
avait été fait on met deux jusqu'en mai
2014 où on nous avait parlé de ce centre
de loisirs des bruyères qui devait être
rénové et puis finalement on apprend
mais 2015 que tout est arrêté on nous
annonce aussi qu on a besoin d'eux
de ce budget pour rénover les écoles moi
ça me pose la question de la promesse
qui a été faite et de l'absence de la
respecter et aussi sur la gestion
puisque en un an on nous annonce que
toutes les écoles doivent être faites
donc comment a pu ne pas attendre ne pas
anticiper à ce point la réfection de
toutes les écoles
donc je suis assez mitigé sur le débat
de madame côté millard et est vraiment
un manque de communication de
transparence et un problème aussi sur
tout ce qui est programme immobilier qui
a marqué beaucoup ces dernières années
alors votre campagne stephenie jamin
tourne autour de valeurs d'écologie de
solidarité justement l'écologie qui est
l'un des axes prioritaires de de votre
programme vous souhaitez porter un réel
développement durable aux
clayes-sous-bois quelles sont les
propositions que vous avez en la matière
alors effectivement oui alors le
développement durable c'est quelque
chose qui est très important puisque on
est quand même dans un climat d'urgence
climatique et environnementale donc on a
envie proposer des vraies mesures
notamment sur la végétalisation des
espaces qui permettent de désinformer
viser les sols et ça c'est très
important surtout quand on sait que ces
dernières années il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont été beaucoup d'arbres qui
ont été supprimés beaucoup d espace qui
ont été bétonnée donc on veut travailler
là dessus on veut également travailler
sur les audits énergétiques de tous les
bâtiments publics puisque parce qu'il ya
pas mal de
d'investissement qui ont été faits sur
ces dernières années mais il n'y a pas
de la déperdition d'énergie
donc il y as a également tout ce qui est
sur les mobilités douces les pistes
cyclables oakley on les compte elles ne
sont pas entretenues et puis encore une
fois il ya des investissements qui sont
faits sur des exemples sur l'anneau jean
jaurès
non pas la news je reste mais sur la
jules ferry pardon et pas de piste
cyclable de prévu donc la mobilité douce
est vraiment un sujet auquel est surtout
que c'est une ville qui est de plus en
plus engorgées avec tous les centres
commerciaux aux alentours donc la
mobilité douce est quelque chose de très
importantes alors autres sujets que vous
souhaitez porter ses plus de
transparence une démocratie locale plus
transparents tenir par exemple neuf
conseils municipaux parents et instaurer
un temps d'échangé entre les clés siens
et les élus au début de ces séances
pourquoi vouloir aller dans ce sens
alors je pense qu'il est important de
redonner confiance aux clés siens parce
que depuis quelques années comme je vous
disais il ya vraiment un manque de
transparence et de communication
dès que ceux des classes ayant besoin
d'une équipe municipale qui soient à
leur écoute qui puisse répondre à leurs
questions qu'ils soient présentes à
leurs côtés et c'est surtout qu'on les
écoute
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est une liste
citoyenne est attentif à ce qu'on veut
faire attention à nos ados à nos
concitoyens donc on veut vraiment
travailler là dessus il ya toute cette
partie conseil municipal mais il ya
aussi plus sûres
travailler avec la minorité mais une
minorité municipale leur confiant la
présidence d'une commission d'appel
d'offres donc on veut travailler sur ce
sujet et notre rôle aussi ces deux pour
bien vivre ensemble c'est de dirt
expliquer aux gens ce qui compte ce que
les élus doivent faire comme mon travail
et quelles sont les preuves
les prérogatives de chacun autour de la
pédagogie autour des missions d'un
conseil municipal tout à fait pour que
chacun comprenne ce qu'on peut faire ce
qu'on peut pas faire pourquoi es tu
vraiment cette souci de transparence
paix et pédagogique qui permettra un
mieux vivre ensemble et un meilleur
respect de chacun et c'est seulement
échanger ou c'est aussi leur donner
peut-être la part à certaines décisions
on voit là la démocratie participative
être l'un des thèmes aussi de cette
campagne des municipales
comment vous voyez les choses alors
effectivement on a envie d'ouvrir les
commissions à des clés siens qui les
modalités sont encore à définir mon
envie de leur ouvrir des commissions
notamment les commissions des affaires
scolaires où on pourrait peut-être
intégrer les parents d'élèves de manière
plus systématique également les
animateurs des centres de loisirs qui
ont leur mot à dire sur les projets et
puis toutes les personnes qui ont envie
de participer peuvent venir aux
commissions il ya ce côté là est
également un budget participatif avec
des projets pour l'intérêt général ou
les questions pourront décider ce sera
votée encore après mais de participer au
développement de leur ville un mot aussi
votre regard pour terminer nous reste 30
secondes sur l'intégration des
clayes-sous-bois dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines elle en fait
partir depuis 2016 on rappelle que pour
ces élections municipales on élit aussi
les conseillers communautaires
quel regard vous portez sur cette
intégration de la commune gic 30
secondes mais du coup ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est que j'ai effectivement
il faut qu'on tienne nos engagements et
prenne nos responsabilités par rapport à
saint quentin en yvelines
il va falloir que
on arrête de dire que c'est toujours la
faute de 50 ans quand il ya le moindre
souci au niveau de la voirie des
éclairages il faut quelqu'un en mairie
qui sont capables de relayer les
demandes de suivre des dossiers donc ça
je pense que c'est très important et
c'est ce sur quoi on veut s'engager pour
les prochaines années
vos prochains rendez vous de campagne
avec attention nous tenons des réunions
publiques le 29 février à andré proulx
de 10h à 12h le dimanche 8 mars jour de
la femme de 16 heures à 18 heures aux
commandes du château et ensuite à rené
coty doucement de 20h30 à 22h30
merci stéphanie jamin tête de liste
d'énergie positive aux clayes-sous-bois
face à vous je le rappelle l'adjointe au
maire à l'éducation anne-claire frémont
le premier adjoint actuel philippe
guiguen et l'élu d'opposition nicolas
hué donc on en parlait dans cette
cinquième candidature celle d'olivier
augustin pour lutte ouvrière avant de
vous laisser je vous rappelle ce rendez
vous ce soir 20h suite des débats en vue
du premier tour des élections
municipales en débat consacré ce soir à
20h sur tv 78 et radio sensations
yvelines à la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]